hello i think uh uh welcome uh this will
be the first in a series of lectures on
on physics and my goal is really uh to
give you an intuitive feeling of what
physics is all about because especially
on the mechanic side of things you know
projectile motion and force and moments
and it's actually pretty intuitive so
well let me know if i'm if i'm not
giving you intuitive sense let's start
with with probably the most basic uh
formula in physics and a lot of you all
have already seen this is you know
distance
equal to
velocity
times time
and you might have seen it in different
forms you might have seen it written as
distance is equal to rate times time or
distance is equal to speed times time or
you know instead of a d if you're doing
it in a math class sometimes i'll write
an s for distance because they use d for
derivatives but uh it's all the same
thing it just says the distance you
travel is equal to the speed or the
velocity you travel times time
now before i do a couple of quick just
example problems just to hit this point
home i just want to make a slight
distinction between velocity and speed
so
when people use it in everyday language
it tends to be
used interchangeably it's kind of how
fast are you going right velocity versus
speed but technically there's a
difference velocity is a vector
is a vector
measurement
and speed is a scalar and and i probably
have already confused you and all you
have to know is a velocity i mean a
vector has a magnitude and a direction
right so if i were to give a velocity i
i really shouldn't just say 5 miles per
hour i should say 5 miles per hour north
or instead of saying five miles per hour
north i could say negative five miles
per hour south right those would be the
same thing whilst
speed or a scalar only has magnitude so
speed would say five miles per hour but
i don't know what direction i'm going in
i could be going forward backward left
right north south up down who knows
so that's the technical difference
between uh velocity between a vector and
a scalar in between velocity and speed
and it might not seem so obvious that
probably on these few example problems
we're doing right now
the distinction probably could be used
interchangeably but later on as we
progress to fancier problems
i think you'll see that velocity is a
more useful notion because you have a
there's the idea of a negative velocity
right you can go in one direction which
is positive and then you could turn
around and go negative and uh with speed
it's only
there's no direction involved so with
that said i don't want to dwell on that
too much because i don't want to make
you think that this is difficult let's
do a couple of really quick problems i
mean if i were to go
let's say i went
50 meters
so 50 meters so distance is equal to 50
meters so i go 50 meters and time
is equal to and this should really be
well i guess you could say distance or
you could say actually change in
distance but for for the problems we'll
do it doesn't make a difference let's
say the time
is once again this could be change in
time as well the time is 10 seconds
10 seconds
so if we use that formula we have 50
meters
is equal to velocity
times
10 seconds
so this is a pretty simple algebra
equation if we want to solve for
velocity we just derive but we just
divide both sides of this equation by 10
seconds and i'm doing this because i
actually want to show you that when you
divide the numbers you should also
divide the units with them and then
you'll always end up with the right
units so let's let's multiply both sides
of this equation by 1 over 10 seconds so
then i get
1
over 10
seconds
times 50 meters is equal to velocity
times well i'll write it all out later
on i'll skip some steps
all right this obviously cancels out
that's why we did in the first
in the first place
and then the 50 and the 10 cancel and
this becomes 5.
so we're left with 5
a meter in the numerator
and the seconds in the denominator
i could write it as sec or just with an
s so 5 meters per second is our velocity
you could have done that but
the one thing i just wanted to highlight
is that the units you can you can
manipulate with the numbers and then you
always get the right answer and it might
have been obvious in this case you
didn't have to do it this way but once
again later on when we start doing power
and work and
energy
which is actually the same thing as work
but once we start doing those things
then the units might not seem so obvious
so it's good to to be able to
deal with the units this way
so and you know we could we could solve
if i said that the velocity velocity is
equal to seven
meters
per second
and that time
is equal to i don't know five seconds
how far did i go well i could use that
formula again
distance is equal to velocity seven
meters per second
times time which is 5
seconds and once again not only can we
multiply the numbers 7 times 5 is 35
but we can multiply the units so we have
meters over seconds
times seconds you can almost treat them
like variables but they're not they're
units
so meters over seconds times seconds
well then a second in the numerator and
the second of the denominator cancel out
so you're left with 35 meters and there
not only do you have the right number
you have the right units and actually
this is going to be super useful when
you when you have you know if you have
to convert from centimeters to meters
and you know and and you know hours to
seconds and all that and maybe we'll do
a couple of examples actually a while
ago i actually already made a separate
video on unit conversion but and that's
going to come in really handy
when we when we do the physics
without our way let's make things a
little bit more complicated
image
so
most of what you've probably experienced
so far you know distance is equal to
velocity times time or
or rate times time is where velocity is
constant right where you're you know
you're going 30 meters per second you're
always going to 30 meters per second and
you'll stay going 30 meters per second
but we know
from moving in like we moving generally
that uh that your velocity isn't i mean
sometimes you're stationary and then
sometimes you're moving and in order to
start stationary and then get moving you
had to your velocity had to change right
so
how could we describe a change in
velocity and and once again i don't
think this is i'm teaching you anything
fundamentally new
you know what it is it's acceleration
so velocity
is acceleration
times time and there's a pretty good
analogy here right just as
distance
is
velocity times time velocity is
acceleration times time or you could
view it as
the change in distance
over the change in time
is velocity
while the change in velocity versus the
change in time
is equal to acceleration
oh my phone's ringing let me let me
answer that a little bit later because
because once again you are more
important
so where was i oh okay oh i was saying
how they're very similar right
at least there's there's kind of a an
analogy here so what what can we do with
this notion well i'm going to do a bunch
of
what i think you'll find is pretty
useful they're called projectile
problems and projectile problems involve
the acceleration of gravity and you know
what we could do
other acceleration problems um
you know involving an acceleration of
car et cetera et cetera and actually i
probably will do that but the
acceleration of gravity
is
well it's actually 9.8 meters per second
again downwards and once again
acceleration is a is a uh
it's actually not down it's towards the
center of the earth acceleration is also
a vector quantity but for the sake of r
for for the sake of our computations
we'll just say 10 meters per second so
acceleration
is equal to g g is normally the variable
used when people talk about the
acceleration of gravity
and let's say that equals 10
meters per second squared
i know what you're thinking this is a
this is kind of a strange um
set of units meters per second squared
it's hard to visualize well that's
acceleration and i think
once you see it used in some of these
formulas it'll start to make a little
sense in terms of
in terms of
how these units work out
so let's start with a fairly simple
problem let's say i drop a rock from
i don't recommend you to do this you
could kill somebody let's say i drop not
a rock a penny from the empire state
building and i'm assuming no air
resistance
and actually i just looked at the clock
and i realized that i'm i'm running out
of time so i'm going to actually start
this problem in the next presentation
i'll see you soon